[Musik]
ganz hinten im centovalli sagen sich
nicht nur fuchs und hase gute nacht
beide können wenn sie wollen auch dem
größten lebenden schweizer clown schöne
träume wünschen denn hier wohnt der
clown dimitri denn jedes kind kennt und
dessen breites lachen auch alle
erwachsenen lieben bei ihm sind wir zu
gast um über sein leben zu
philosophieren und die frage ob man mit
lachfalten im gesicht und poesie im
herzen das altwerden in schach halten
kann oder ob auch er der glückspilz der
am freitag 80 geworden ist sich oft
hinter sind über den moment wenn der
allerletzte vorhang fällt
dimitri noch nicht sagen die
allermeisten kennen sie als clown der
nicht spricht darum wie würden sie ohne
worte auf die frage antworten welche
gefühle löste in ihnen ihr achtzigsten
geburtstag aus
so glücklich möchte ich mit 80 auch sein
ich auch nicht reden das wird schwierig
58 minuten schweigen
das ist das problem wie wir einen anfang
sie die mit region zu den wenigen die
die ganze geschichte ohne worte erzählen
könnten war das angeboren konnten sie
schon als kleiner knirps den wütenden
lehrer wieder zum lachen bringen
das konnte ich allerdings ja und das
darum wurde ich auch grauen es ist so
natürlich man kann ja nicht nur mit den
worten zum lachen bringen es braucht
irgendwie die mimik die ich etwas
besonderes was nun eigentlich ist eine
story im kopf nein das licht das nicht
es ist ja meistens improvisiert
natürlich also vor allem wenn man im
leben wenn man die kameraden oder auch
fremde menschen oder eben den lehrer wie
damals als kind zum lachen bringen will
da kann man nur improvisieren muss man
irgendwie gewisse momente schnappen und
die ausnützen und ihnen war was geben
schon als kind mir nicht wieso fiel und
darum machen wir die nächste stunde doch
mit worten schlage ich vor aber wegen
ihrer fähigkeit alles eigentlich ohne
worte erzählen zu können haben daniela
tami und maurizio domizzi von radio
spitzenreiter jana ja einen schönen film
über sie gemacht wo nicht gesprochen hat
und diesen fehlen meine damen und herren
zeigen wir ihnen gleich im anschluss an
dieses gespräch dann auch aber ich
konnte den kollegen ein paar bilder
abluchsen weil ich gedacht habe ich das
eigentlich weil es ist ein film der eine
reisezeit von ihr zurück in den zirkus
knie warum das enthüllt sich dann noch
das leben ist ja auch eine reise also
wir können das dramaturgisch parallel
schalten und jede reise beginnt ja mit
dem aufbruch
und wir sehen hier wie sie bevor sie
hier wegziehen richtung zu einem holz l
franken
adieu sagen wo steht der hand also das
ist ja eigentlich nur eine einen fall
für elefanten ein theater elefant aber
eben die ist es so schön und so rührend
dass sich zu immer eine beziehung hatte
weil ich konnte ja nicht einen
lebendigen elefanten bei mir zu hause
haben und bevor ich eben den großen
besuch die große reise antreten zum
zirkus knie vor allem um die elefanten
zu begrüßen
er nehme ich abschied von meinem ersatz
elefanten elefant und der steht in
theaterform gehen wer schon theater ja
und während so imhof fernsehen in ihrem
haus in ihrem atelier wo sie trainieren
auf diesen heiligen zirkus boden ich
setze sogar ein für einen zirkus nicht
und da habe ich genau ist ein echter
knie stuhl mit dem plüsch und ich habe
einmal bekommen
der wille war da und ihr stuhl ist auch
weit unterwegs gewesen
mein stuhl ist ein besonderer stuhl eine
artistenschule der ist jahrelang mit mir
auf tournee gegangen
der ist so verstärkt da und ich habe
handstände gemacht auf diesem stuhl und
salzer vom stuhl runter und so
darum ist er auch ein ein historischer
stuhl fühle ich mich sehr wohl muss ich
sagen mit hunderten von masken puppen
sie scheinen ein leidenschaftlich auf
asiatischer sammler zu sein das bin ich
allerdings ich kann nichts wegschmeißen
ich kann gewisse gegenstände so
[Musik]
recyclingmaterial das sammle ich alles
unten und mache dann so objekte daraus
nicht aber immer mit einem clown
verbunden aber eben masken instrumente
puppen marionetten das sammle ich das
liebe ich nicht und in dieser zirkuswelt
sitzen wir und ich finde das wunderbar
und wir haben also ist das kapitel im
film eingespielt der aufbruch jedes
leben beginnt mit dem aufbau
auch ist es war ich habe das gelesen als
siebenjähriger wussten sie ich werde
klar
ja das stimmt das ist so ich gehe mit
meinen eltern in den zirkus knie wir
gehen immer von ascona zu fuß nach
lokalen noch in den knie jedes jahr im
november nicht und da war ich sieben
jahre alt er war ein clown im knie der
hieß angriff und er hat mich sehr
beeindruckt und dann habe ich mein vater
gefragt machte das ist dass sein beruf
oder machte das jeden tag oder und er
hat mir das genau erklärt mein vater
weißt du das ist auch ein künstler der
muss auch viel üben viel arbeiten du
siehst ja wunderbar instrumente spielt
wie er sich bewegt wie acrobat und
tänzer ist ja dann wusste ich das wird
mein beruf das möchte ich mache von da
an kein piloten wunsch mehr kein
lokführer klar kein lokführer und nix ja
was waren sie für ein kind waren sich
schon der klassenclown der außenseiter
ein mädchenschwarm oder was also ich
habe früh entdeckt dass wenn man die
leute zum lachen bringen kann dass man
mehr erfolg hat ja dann ist man beliebt
nicht weil wenn man dann so eine art
kompanie kalt wird oder klassenclown
nicht dann dann lieben dich alle nicht
und ich habe es eben sogar fertig
gebracht auch die lehrer georg das zum
lachen zu bringen wusste aber dann immer
genau wann aufhören damit sie nicht
plötzlich mit mir schimpfen oder dass es
dann umkippte ins gegenteil als als
sympathie
sie hatten beides spontanität und gute
planung sehe das gute planung würde wir
sagen ist eine deutschschweizer
eigenschaft was war das für ein haushalt
mehr tessinerin ascona oder deutsch
schweizer haushalt also ich würde sagen
ausgesprochen beides weil der tessiner
hat ja vielleicht mehr fähigkeit zur
kommunikation auch das lateinische
italienische ein bisschen ist viel
spontaner viele erzählt freudiger und
auch fantasievoll nicht
und das stimmt schon der
deutschschweizer ist vielleicht ein
bisschen reservierte und ein bisschen
überlegte nicht sie sind beides jetzt
und das ist die wunderbare mischung das
ist mein glück nicht aber ich habe noch
russisches blut das hab ich recherchiert
dürfen wir das ja voll offen legen weil
die großmutter glaube ich ja die hat
eine eskapade begangen jawohl das war
eine berühmte eskapade und über die kann
man heute ruhig sprechen ist muss er
großmutter ist natürlich längstens
gestorben und meine mutter auch und
meine mutter hat mir das auch anvertraut
dass eben sie eigentlich eine tochter
von einem russischen vater ist und das
hat uns immer sehr gefreut also ich
finde das sehr spannend dass ich da ein
viertel drucks binden haben plötzlich
ein russe vorbei der sich im moment weiß
jahres war es war eine der musste
flüchten aber in der ersten revolution
ich weiß nicht mehr genau an die war
1905 oder sogar ein
und der war dann student und wohnte bei
meiner großmutter und die wahlen ist
sehr schöne frau und dann haben die
gemacht weshalb menschen ja was hat die
menschen auch manchmal machen nicht weil
er mit freuden und und ihr der mann der
meint ja sei der vater der hat das
gewusst das ist ein kuckuckskind war
wer nein eben nicht das ist ja natürlich
auch das spannende der mann von meiner
großmutter
der hat eigentlich ein leben lang
geglaubt es wäre sein kind ja das ist
halt so das kann man jetzt nicht wieder
gut nein einen grund kann man sagen dass
russisches artisten blut in die familie
dimitri gebracht ja ich finde das sehr
spannend nicht man hat dann auch
herausgefunden dass der his morozov und
ich habe mich ein bisschen erkundigt und
dann ein russe hat mir gesagt mensch du
bist sogar vielleicht verwandt mit dem
berühmten models of der wasser ein
kunst mit 10 in in moskau und dann habe
ich natürlich sofort daran geglaubt das
muss unbedingt gewesen sein aber das
weiß man ja nicht
aber künstler blutspuren alle wir kommen
noch drauf die kinder die enkel also war
und vielleicht auch sonst waren da schon
viele gene die ein bisschen anders
gekickt haben als bei vielen und sie
wurden clown musste man was war ihr plan
als siebenjährige haben sie gesagt ich
lernte dass wenn ich groß bin oder wo
konnte man klar und lernen damals also
ich habe immer gemeldet also wie es hat
man mit meinen eltern und also ich
möchte klar werden wie macht man das ja
meine eltern waren ein bisschen
verzweifelt weil es gibt ja keine
clownschule und sie haben dann
herausgefunden dass eigentlich die beste
in moskau wäre aber das war unmöglich
ich konnte nicht nach moskau gehen
sowieso in moskau und die schweiz hatten
nicht sehr gute drähte das war der
kommunismus tor und schweiz kapitalisten
das wäre nicht gegangen frankreich werde
vielleicht gegangen war in frankreich
hatte damals eine ehre linksgerichtete
regierung gut da so gut es war so und es
war richtig so warum nicht und ich habe
dann meine wg gemacht ich wo ich bin auf
umwegen zur gefahr geworden
töpfer jahr zuerst opfer köpfe drehen
das war ein wunderschöner beruf mit
meinen händen künstlerisch handwerklich
und dann doch irgendwann aber auch bei
ganz großen gelernt bei marcel marceau
und so irgendwann haben sie das mädchen
dann richtig gelernt
natürlich also dass das war dann eine
wichtige etappe thema so zuerst schüler
und dann in seiner truppe aber vorher
habe ich natürlich musik probiert zu
studieren also nicht wie ein
berufsmusiker aber in berlin am konzil
wären nicht oder dann habe ich akrobatik
stunden genommen ballettstunden und
ich habe dann theater gespielt mit den
studenten bühnen und so weiter und so
fort
das ist manchmal eine einsame sache
viele leute die ganz an die spitze
kommen trainieren dann wenn die anderen
trinken gehen oder sich vergebens
manchmal viel investition in einsame
trainingsstunden also es war schon eine
in einem gewissen sinn eine einsame
sache weil wenn die anderen eben wie du
sagst
die gingen dann vielleicht noch irgendwo
in eine warum haben da getanzt und jazz
gehört oder so ich weiß noch dass in
bern das ist der honky tonk oder ich
weiß nicht mehr genau wie und ich sagte
mir es tut mir leid also ich habe keine
lust
ich hätte vielleicht schon ein bisschen
lust gehabt aber ich wollte eben zuhause
meine instrumente üben und das braucht
immer viele stunden aber mir hat das
freude gemacht das war der zielstrebige
dimitri kann nur so zu einem der ganz
großen klar uns der schweiz ohnehin aber
auch auf der welt werden konnte aber
auch der einsame spitzen klauen braucht
auf den seinem künstlerleben die anderen
und in diesem film habe ich eine schöne
szene gefunden wo sie einen anderen
treffen der eine bedeutung hatte auf
ihren wegen
[Musik]
schon bald für den schutz und die
batterie
in monaco
[Musik]
während wir das ist eine ganz wunderbare
stimme haben partitur ja eigentlich
passt glaube ich aber ich komme mir
nicht so gut in die höhe
und darum haben wir immer zusammen das
abkommen getroffen dass der roberto die
zweite stimme oben macht ist das war ein
älteres haus normalerweise eine terz
unterhalb der sonst die zweite stimme
eine terz tiefer und ja sie haben das
gedreht oder ja wir haben das einfach
umgedreht also meine stimme war immer
die erste stimme und normalerweise ist
die zweite stimme eine terz unten und
roberto weil er eine höhere stimme hat
er eine kerze oben die zweite stimme
gesungen und ja roberto das ist mein
lieber freund mein kumpel mein sinn
kamerad und und seit jahren sind oder
schon vor jahrzehnten sind sie mit
roberto durch die lande gezogen
ich weiß dass war ich war 17 jährig
hatte meine ersten aufträge beim
luzerner tagblatt um nebenher ein
bisschen als junger journalist ja was zu
versuchen und einer der ersten aufträge
war die mikro bertow singen im luzerner
kkl ein theater und ich war so erstaunt
dass der berühmte mine sind ich weiß
noch den titel abgeschrieben
dimitri ein mime öffnet den mund weil
hat das viele erstaunt dass sie dass der
mir auch noch ganz andere
ausdrucksmittel hat oder nur mich ja gut
da so ich muss vielleicht ein klein
bisschen korrigieren ich war ja nicht
nur eine spezielle ich war vor allem
frauen der auch mit nicht und das
eigentlich meistens sturm ist nicht
immer aber ich habe ja auch die worte
gebraucht ich habe auch sehr viel so
ramelow gemacht diese diese worte
mutationen sprach imitationen
das hat gesungen habe ich immer am ball
das hatte ich nicht mitbekommen ich hab
gedacht als clown spricht er nicht und
jetzt singt er sinkt aber wunderbar und
das ist natürlich harmonie mit roberto
ihr müsst haben auch nicht sein sonst
ist es nicht schön
ja gab es im berufsleben auch die
momente wo nicht aber nie war sondern
kommt
grenznahe auf einen anderen der ebenso
gut ist eben ihm singen nein jetzt in
anderen sparten beim klang sein wollten
sie immer der beste sein und ja
natürlich also ich habe das schon
angestrebt das hat schon spaß gemacht
aber ich hatte natürlich leichtes spiel
weil es gibt sehr wenig clowns nicht ich
habe ja auch immer gesagt ich bin der
beste grauen von ascona
aber warum weil ich war der einzige es
gibt sehr wenig konkurrenz auf unserem
gebiet
aber wenn schon dann auch weltweit ja
aber es gibt nicht man kann man kann sie
an zehn fingern abzählen diddy diddy
bekannten guten raums aber sie wollen zu
den ganz guten gehören dazu
also ich wäre schon gerne in diese ziele
serie gekommen und irgendwie das ich
weiß nicht ob ich das geschafft habe
aber ist für mich war das schon immer
ein ansporn auch in der schule oder
irgendwo im sport oder beim schwimmen
oder ich war ein fanatischer schwimmer
nicht ich habe auch wettkämpfe gemacht
und bin sogar in frankreich ein mal
zweiter geworden nicht also aber leider
nicht erst dann und dann finden sie es
nicht so lustig wenn sie nicht erster
bester sind ja also ich war dann schon
ein bisschen sauer aber nur mir
gegenüber nicht
trotzdem suchen sie zu den ganz guten
zwei jahren auf einem gebiet das ganz
große gibt mach so haben wir schon
genannt es gibt in einem dokumentarfilm
den ich gesehen habe wie eine szene
damals als im knie spielen da habe ich
war plötzlich charlie chaplin dort und
sie stehen neben ihm ja dass das war
natürlich ein einer der größten momente
in meinem leben weil chaplin kann ja
nicht dich kalt lassen vor allem als
komiker als clown weil chaplin ja
eigentlich auch eine art clown war und
immer noch ist im film nicht dass der
große vorteil vom film dass das weiter
lebt aber diese große persönlichkeit
kennen lernen zu tun
und es hat ihm sogar gefallen meine
nummer im knie ja so dass ist der himmel
das ist der sound himmel und die
heiligsprechung wenzel lag das ist gut
was du machst allerdings ist eine
heiligsprechung werden das war wirklich
ein schöner moment ich habe es eben nur
im film gesehen aber die leute haben
geklatscht
standing ovations für diesen mann der
die zeit geprägt hat da haben sie
gedacht ich hab den richtigen beruf
gewählt
also ich denke eine größere bestätigung
kann man nicht kann man nicht haben
also ich war so der cree hat mir noch
gesagt heute bringst du dem chaplin die
den strauß den blumenstrauß und gehst
jetzt ins publikum und ich war so nervös
so lampenfieber das sich in die falsche
reihe ging also weil ich musste da durch
die reihen gehen bis zu ihm der saß
neben ihm seine frau nicht und dann muss
ich wieder zurück da egal gereicht dass
ich ihn dann erwischt
da hat selbst beim damals schon erfahren
clown das herz geschlagen und
lampenfieber jahres lampenfieber habe
ich eigentlich immer wenn ich weiß dass
irgendeine große persönlichkeit im
publikum sitzt aber noch umso mehr wenn
ich dann diese persönlichkeit irgendwie
noch ja begrüßen soll oder ein
blumenstrauß bringen und diese hommage
an den großen komiker und und haben sie
nur dann lampenfieber oder wenn sie das
darin zentrum sind und gehen raus in die
manege raus auf die bühne ist noch
lampenfieber heute nein es hört dann
schon auf also entweder habe ich tag und
nacht lampenfieber oder ich habe mir
dann das wichtig starke lampenfieber das
ist aber nur in diesen momenten auch zum
glück für geht es dann nach der
vorstellung
sie haben weil sie so berühmt und gut
geworden sind auch andere größen des
öffentlichen lebens gekannt und
hintersinn zum beispiel max frisch da
kommt man dann in
kontakt würden sie sagen durch diesen
klang beruf gab es dinge im leben die
man nie erlebt hätte wie war das
plötzlich mit dem bekannter klang mit
dem schriftsteller mit frisch
kommunizieren ja dass das sind schon
besondere begebenheiten also ich muss
sagen unser beruf ist einer der
schönsten berufe die es gibt es auch
schwierig aber wir haben eine art
passepartout alle alle alle menschen
wollen uns kennenlernen wollen uns
einladen haben freude mit uns am selben
tisch zu sein
und so hat sich dies große glücklich
aber ehrlich gesagt denn günter grass
noch vor max frisch kennengelernt und
wir haben hier gerade hier wo wir jetzt
sitzen im garten sehr viele feste gebaut
nicht und dann kamen neben max frisch
und günter grass und günter grass hat
dann grilliert er war ein wunderbarer
kochen wir hatten es sehr sehr lustig
sehr schön da kam noch der höller noch
um solche leute und wichtig war dann so
ein kleiner clown der irgendwie beliebt
war aber ich habe hier noch noch nie was
gelesen weder von frisch rasiert von
grafs ist nicht er sich schämte mich
eigentlich und konnte sich nie richtig
mitreden da in diesen hohen gesprächen
nicht ich glaube sie untertreibung sie
haben sich ja nicht frisch gesagt sie
hätten den besuch der alten dame gesetzt
oder so sie haben das ja also gut ich
habe ja dass das hat mich gerettet das
sich eigentlich fast alle theaterstücke
gesehen habe nicht besuch der alten dame
habe ich gesehen und aber den dürrenmatt
kannten sie auch unter den kannten sie
nicht persönlich also die haben wir
natürlich besuch der alten dame das ist
hüfte entschuldigung
das ist ja mal eine fraktur in mathe
nein aber ich habe ich habe dann
natürlich habe ich mich an die
blechtrommel gewagt nachdem ich dann den
günter kennengelernt habe habe natürlich
auch andorra und solche stücke gesehen
von frisch und so also so ganz
analphabet weil ich nicht aber ich muss
schon sagen dass das theater
[Musik]
zur literatur und hat ihnen das gebracht
haben dort zum beispiel der paladin das
gefallen andorra von frisch ja es hat
mir sehr gefallen ja wobei ich habe zum
beispiel ein stück gesehen oder aus der
grass geschrieben hat irgendetwas
revolution wird geprobt oder irgendetwas
ein stück wo sie in einem theater eine
revolution darstellen und draußen
passiert die wir griechenland nicht die
wirklichkeit überrennt das theaterstück
und das hat mir eigentlich nicht
gefallen also es war für mich kein gutes
theaterstück und diese feste waren das
dionysische feste wo der wein floss und
die künstler ganz wild wie also der wein
floss sie können es kaum glauben aber
die wahre liebe dunkel
die taiwanische grade und immer im kopf
beieinander
also ich habe mir das bewundern die ich
nach einem halben glas bin ich war ich
schon aber es war schön waren das
persönliche freundschaften geworden
ja so ganz bestimmt ganz bestimmt also
mit frischer war ich auch schon
eingeladen bei ihm und und er wollte so
rein mal dass ich eine rolle spiele in
einem film also man hat aus dem mann tao
kollegen etwas ein antrag ja ja hat er
eine figur gesucht
diese rolle spielt und er hat an mich
gedacht aber sie haben es nicht lange
dauern ein zu wenig komisch ja ja nein
montag gemeint ist muss ich sagen meiner
lieblingsbücher aber ich hab sie jetzt
wieder gelöst es ist so kalt die
beziehungen bei frisch sind so richtig
fröstelnd kalt zwischen mann und frau
und das ist es bei ihnen ist nicht so
richtig jahr ist und kann und ich habe
ähnliche erlebnisse schon gehabt mit
angeboten zum beispiel gras wollte dass
sich eine marke spiele in einem stück
das man auch verfilmt hat und ich weiß
noch wir waren in berlin
und grass fragt mich ob ich diese rolle
spielen will um dann war auch ein freund
dem gemeinsamen freund der orell nicolae
der flötist der wahl hinten lag und dann
hat er mir gesagt ein gemacht dass das
licht das ist nichts für mich
und das ist auch ganz eine schreckliche
rolle also total komisch und poetisch
also nichts für mich denn ich weiß eines
ihrer lieblings zitate um einen clown zu
definieren ist ein clown ist ein handeln
der poet von henry miller
ja da habe ich von ihnen gelesen glauben
ist ein handeln der pole muss politisch
sein ist sein
also ich das ist einsatz einer meiner
lieblings setzte weil das ist das größte
kompliment was man einen clown machen
kann der clown ist ein handel der
dichter oder projekt nicht und effektiv
ich habe mir immer wieder überlegt was
was bedeutet das ja der der dichte der
nimmt die feder und schreibt oder geht
und computer sei egal aber er schreibt
worte und seine poesie übermittelt sich
wie schrift wer buch wie er wollte und
der clown
er ist ein poet mit seinem körper mit
seinem ausdruck mit seinen instrumenten
mit er ist selber der dichte der keine
worte braucht und keine bücher selber
die geschichte ja ja ja und dafür lieben
ihn die menschen alle so in einem
zirkuszelt stelle ich mir vor sitzt der
bankdirektor der straßen kehren die
kinder die alten aber wenn der clown
dann welt erfolg hat dann ist er auch
ein liebkind bei den mächtigen dieser
welt und habe ich im film auch eine ganz
schöne szene gefunden
ja
[Musik]
das historische hat eine frau die es zur
bundesrätin gebracht hat und die ganz
freudig zu sein hat das war nicht nur so
weil der drehbuchautor gesagt habt ihr
wir inszenieren als sind sie wirklich
gefreut
ja also es ist wir kennen uns schon eine
weile diese wunderschöne charmante frau
sie hat sogar bevor sie bundesrätin war
einmal an einer vernissage für eine
einführung gesprochen in aarau nicht für
für mich für da war irgendwie ich weiß
ja nicht auch schon in der politik ab
und ja ich mag sie sehr gut ich sagen
jeweils zum spaß was meine freundin ja
das ist eine frau die jetzt zu den
mächtigen gehört und das brachte mich
auf die überlegung wie soll es der clown
mit der macht halten soll man mit der
elite auf du und du sein soll man mit
einem menschen macht und sein oder
könnte ja auch sagen der clown sollte
eine distanz bewahren
das ist eine sehr schwierige frage die
ich hier auch nicht so klipp und klar
antworten kann es gibt ja immer diese
meinung und ich bin auch oft diese
meinung man sollte auch mit dem feind
[Musik]
kommunizieren theologie sieren wissen
was denkt er anstatt einfach nur
bekämpfen nicht und in der politik
kinder auf der welt beobachte ich das
immer wieder denke mensch wenn doch nur
die kommunikation da wäre und wenn hier
und da vielleicht ein bisschen humor
noch darin wäre nicht das würde sicher
vielen viel helfen wollen sie denn als
clown etwas verändern in der welt also
verändern ist ein großes wort ich bilde
mir nicht ein dass wir
viel verändern können aber wir können
sicher wir könnten sicher viel mehrere
verbindungen schaffen
ich habe zum beispiel immer das
bedürfnis auch in unserem theater oder
wo ich auch immer bin leute miteinander
zusammen zu bringen und manchmal auch
wirklich gegenteilige menschen nicht von
verschiedenen ich erinnere mich an eine
szene so an einem tisch waren wie und
wieso wie von mir war eine von der lega
die chinesische politik ist natürlich
ein totaler gegner von der lega das ist
ja normal für uns künstler aber warum
weil ein künstler
links ist wie ja weil die künstler sind
ja meistens mehr links nicht das ist
halt so nicht ich bin in keiner partei
aber ich muss jetzt ehrlich sagen ich
habe mit dem menschen wie sami kein wort
gesprochen weil ich einfach nicht konnte
ich dachte mensch also nur nach er hat
meine frau wunder hat mit mir gesprochen
und gesagt du hättest mit ihm sprechen
sollen
du hast doch eine leichtigkeit kontakt
zu schaffen zu kommunizieren und das
wäre doch interessant gewesen mit ihm zu
sprechen und ich habe da wirklich mir
dass hinter die ohren geschrieben was
was mir grund angesagt hat ja die idee
eigentlich dahinter er ist ein gegner
aber darum nicht unbedingt ein feind und
so habe ich die schweiz auch oft erlebt
ein land wo man sich nicht als feinde
betrachtet auch wenn man ein politischer
gegner richtig ab doris leute hat jetzt
ein bisschen zur macht er information
hochstilisiert um das grundsatz thema
hier stellen zu können
was ist ihre beziehung zur schweiz der
gewöhnlichen leute es gibt ja von mani
matter dieses lied warum sie so traurig
sagte die gesichter gesehen wenn die
sitze sind sind wir mindestens der
deutschschweiz urteil auf der anderen
seite des gotthards ein bisschen ein
trauriges volk
also das würde ich jetzt kann ich sagen
es gibt es gibt einen schweizer humor
es gibt wunderbare kabarettisten komiker
ich meine da kann man anfangen bei ebay
emil franz hohler oder das leider
verstorbene caesar kaiser aber auch sein
sohn lorenz keiser und so weiter viele
komiker aber auch in der kunst wenn man
denkt ein tank liebers der in der
bildhauerei für humor entwickelte und
ich finde auch die bergler dienen der
schweiz sie haben humor oder die die
appenzeller haben ein humor und die
vielfältigkeit in der schweiz also ich
finde die schweiz überhaupt kein
trockenes volk das ein klischee von
etwas ja ist nur arbeiten leben um zu
arbeiten statt zu arbeiten um zu leben
das ist ein klischee auch beim publikum
ist das ein unterschied ob sie hier in
ascona spielen oder in zürich wurden ihm
also in der deutschen schweiz habe ich
immer ein sehr gutes publikum und hier
muss ich sagen ist es so gemischt mit
vielen touristen auch aber natürlich
auch einheimischen oder menschen die
hier leben aber die keine tessiner sind
also unter duck das kann man nicht so
gut als repräsentativ nehmen
es ist eine gute mischung nicht aber ich
würde sagen der deutschschweizer hat
etwas das sogar seine gründlichkeit die
ja sprichwörtlich ist die hat auch
vorteile nicht hat auch vorteile und man
darf auch nicht meinen dass alle
deutschschweizer jetzt gegen die
flüchtlinge sind das ist gar nicht wahr
es gibt so viele menschen in der schweiz
die helfen wollen die gut sind die
kommunizieren wollen und unten dass das
beruhigt mich das tröstet nicht spürt
der clown auf der bühne überhaupt ob ein
publikum deutsch
italienisch sogar in russland china die
kulturunterschiede reagiert ein
chinesisches russisches publikum ganz
anderes also ich würde jetzt wenn ich
nicht wüsste in welcher stadt ich spiele
und ich habe ein gutes publikum voll
mehl ich könnte nicht sagen was für eine
nation das ist das könnte ich nicht
sagen aber wenn man natürlich in china
spielt ist das ist schon eine sehr sehr
an der kultur wir haben andere
reaktionen reagieren viel kindlicher
viel eifer die lachen wirklich herzlich
bei diesen unschuldigen gags und so war
dann gegen ein bisschen sophisticated
ist dann sind sie abwartend sie
verstehen zwar aber sie lachen nicht
ja es sehr interessant dabei china ist
vielleicht wirklich das extrem zu europa
man hört ja oft der künstler auf der
bühne lebt von der energie auch des
publikums was da zurückkommt das trägt
ihn brauchen sie ist das wichtig für sie
gibt es abende wo sie ein publikum mehr
liegen als an dem was sie sagen naja die
könnten wissen
lustig und offener sein also früher war
ich sehr empfindlich auf schlechtes
publikum und dann war ich dann auch
schlecht und das habe ich aber dann bald
gelernt abzustellen das darf man ja
nicht
man darf nie das publikum beschuldigen
es kann gar nichts dafür das ist eine
konstellation von einer gruppe von
menschen die halt so und so eine
reaktion haben es kann auch sein dass
der mehrzahl eher skeptisch
zurückhaltend kühen sind und das strahlt
sich dann aus auf das ganze publikum
spüren sie dann bei man hört man
natürlich schon beim lachen ja beim
applaus und das gegenteil ist natürlich
auch möglich oder es hat paar kinder die
lachen wieso kristall glöckchen nicht
die dann das publikum anstecken zum
lachen
und alle diese facetten die die muss man
einfach akzeptieren aber frustriert sind
sie schon wenn sie seien schlecht das
publikum ist ja nicht mehr das nicht
mehr ich bin jetzt weiß sie
oder sie wissen dass sie gut sind und
beim millionen auf ja nein also manchmal
muss ich mir schon sagen mensch die
reagieren jetzt aber lang nicht oder
überhaupt nicht was ist denn liegt an
mir liegt es an mir ja vielleicht liegt
es an mir und dann während der
vorstellung sage ich mir nein es kam
nicht an dir liegen die tasten tausende
male gespielt und tausende male haben
wir die leute gelacht also es kann nicht
an dir liegen muss ich mir aber sagen
jaja sind sie süchtig nach dem applaus
nach so langen jahren ja also man
gewöhnt sich schon dran ist ist
natürlich eine schöne gewohnheit
wenn das dann ein bisschen schwächeres
total
das ist gerade gar nicht stattfindet das
passiert mir nie zum glück also also
süchtig bin ich nicht aber ich bin dort
schon empfindlich natürlich man ist dann
ein bisschen deprimiert und denkt ja was
ist denn heute wieder los
wir haben davon geredet die distanz zur
macht vielleicht da könnte man sagen wer
nicht die rolle des hofnarren hat das
ideale für ein kann wollten sie nie
hofnarr der politik werden also wissen
sie das ist der eine ein thema das wir
immer fasziniert hat dass der hofnarr
eigentlich die aufgabe hat lustig zu
sein
im gegenteil er soll sogar die
wahrheiten sagen aber nur unter der
bedingung dass sie komisch sind dass es
auf komische weise gesprochen und gesagt
wird also dass der könig dann lachen
kann darüber nicht aber auch ganz harte
wahrheiten nicht auch diese tief schon
sagen kann
gallens ja aber wehe wenn er den könig
dann nicht zum lachen bringt das ist
dann hängt er selber das ist dann sehr
kritisch nicht und das macht das das tut
mir tut denn dan dan den clown oder den
narren sehr unter druck setzen das ist
das ist nicht leicht aber aber diese
diese sogenannte narrenfreiheit dass
also der eigentlich alles darf und das
gilt auch für den clown unter der
bedingung dass es komisch dass es
clownesk ist aber sie wenn ich restsee
sie nie ganz in diese rolle geschlüpft
das haben sie auch nie gesucht zum
beispiel die harte kritik dann an den
mächtigen das haben sie nie gesucht
gewollt das habe ich nie gewollt weil
ich interessiere mich für politik ich
engagiere mich auch sozial menschlich
also jahr seien es jetzt eben die
flüchtlinge oder auch was auch himmel
aber dass mische ich sehr ungern mit
meiner kunst als im theater oder auf der
bühne im zirkus da da dass das kann ich
nicht politik machen oder mich so auf
diese weise äußern oder nummern machen
die irgendeine politische message haben
das geht nicht also darum würde man von
ihnen dann auch nie verlangen wollen
sage als clown die ungeschminkte
wahrheit und da fiel mir eine schöne
stelle auf im film wo man sieht dass sie
ein clown sind bei dem die wahrheit
nicht ungeschminkt sondern geschminkt
daher kommt niemand vorbei
vorstellung liebevoll verwandeln sie
sich hier heißt dass man man verbirgt
etwas ist das der grund warum man
geschminkt vor die menschen trägt ja das
ist auch eine sehr interessante frage
das schminken hat eine funktion und zwar
dass man eine art stilisiert wird oder
das ist nicht ist wie im täglichen leben
nicht dass auch das kostüm ist auch gar
nicht sehr viel es braucht nicht riesige
schuhe
es braucht nicht eine brücke und eine
rote nase aber irgendeine umsetzung
recht das braucht es glaube ich der
künstler auf der bühne weil der
naturalismus ist eigentlich nicht sehr
künstlerisch ohne könnten sie wenn jetzt
plötzlich in der ganzen schweiz die
schminke ausgeht notfalls könnten sie
schon auch ohne spielen ja ich bin auch
schon ohne schminke aufgetreten und ich
sehe das auch wenn ich zum beispiel mit
roberto singe und der lustige
geschichten erzähle oder auch eine
komische kopftuch trage und eine frau
spiele machen sich die leute kaputt und
da bin ich nicht geschminkt nicht also
ich glaube nicht dass sein clown ohne
schminke nicht auftreten könnte aber sie
hilft nicht auch schon nur wenn man ein
kind an ein kind denkt das geht in den
zirkus oder geht ins theater und wenn es
einen clown sieht ein bisschen
geschminkt ist ist es natürlich wirklich
ein clown dann auch für ein kindes ist
dann auch optisch die erscheinung ist
das sind wäre enttäuschter ja meine
kinder ein bisschen enttäuscht wenn der
clown nicht geschminkt wäre ja in jungen
jahren habe ich ein
eine zeitlang in genf gelebt im
französischen sprachraum ich erinnere
mich dort hieß es immer le clown blaue
er ist der weiße clown ist der traurige
clown
das gilt bei ihnen überhaupt nicht ja so
gut da müsste man natürlich jetzt
längere erklären ist der cast das
klassische clown trio vor allem in
frankreich dann anfangs letztes
jahrhundert weltberühmt geworden das
klassische trio sich der weißclown denn
mit den projekten weiß geschminkt mit
dem spitzhut dann ist der august mit der
roten nase und den großen schuhe der
naiv ist und dann ist da ja im frack und
so nicht und der täter präsentiert dann
die die direktion oder so aber ich bin
weiß geschminkt also eher wie ein büro
und bin aber eigentlich eher wie ein
august nicht aus ich bin eine mischung
in dem sinn und darum sage ich mir es
kommt eigentlich gar nicht so sehr
darauf an wie man wirklich geschminkt
ist nichts ich bin eine art mischung
zwischen weißgrauen august und büro so
und im leben sind sie dann ganz
eindeutig nur ein glückspilz darf man
das so sagen ich bin absolut ein
glückspilz und ich wollte nur noch
schnell die antwort noch ergänzen von
vorher der clown der traurige clown sei
es nun der weißclown oder der august das
ist ein klischee voll gedeckt das stimmt
das muss nicht sein nein nein das muss
er darf mal traurig sein aber das ist
dann auch nur gespielt das sollte dann
komisch sein seine trauer sollte ein wie
komisch sein aber bei ihnen aus allen
nummern an dem ich mich gerne erinnere
schnell kommt die freude die
lebensfreude zurück sie haben nicht
lange traurig haben sie nicht gern nein
es ist es ist wie soll ich sagen ich
habe eine bestimmte vorstellung vom
clown der clown soll die leute zum
lachen bringen er kann ruhig mal mehr
lange
kohl es einmal traurig sein aber es muss
immer rührend sein
es muss immer irgendeine komische note
haben nicht ist das wie ein kind ein
kind das land das sie sicher traurig
aber manchmal muss man fast lachen über
ein kind das weint weil es kaum so
herzerweichend weinendes umfasst bald
lachen muss nicht weil es die gefühle
sind so stark aber ich glaube nicht an
den sogenannten traurigen clown also es
sei denn er bringe dann dadurch auch die
leute zum lachen dann dann erlaube ich
ihm verzeihe ich ihm seine trauer darf
man sagen dimitri ist aber ein so ein
glückspilz im leben das er immer wieder
schnell gelacht hat das große drama all
den biografien dich ein bisschen gelesen
aber übersieht das ist nicht sie sind
sie sie taumeln tanzen vielleicht eher
auf dem seil als glückspilz durchs leben
also ich sehr gut dass du das wort
glückspilz nochmal aufnimmst welt war
ich dir eine antwort schuldig also ich
bin auf jeden fall ein glückspilz jetzt
in meinem leben in meinem privatleben
nicht ich habe nie wirklich ganz
furchtbare schreckliche
schicksalsschläge erlebt oder dramen
oder wenn vielleicht meine mutter
gestorben ist das war sicher trauriger
weil meine mutter hat sich gefreut auf
den tod also es ist nix nix dramatisches
oder trauriges und das und auch im leben
mit meinen kindern meiner frau meinen
freunden mit meinem beruf mit allem bin
ich wirklich ein großer glückspilzen und
da bin ich sehr dankbar meinem schicksal
meinem leben aber es ist gleichzeitig
auch ein bisschen eine verpflichtung
ich habe immer das gefühl wenn man so
viel glück haben darf ich habe muss ich
auch den menschen was geben ich muss was
zurückgeben ich muss ich muss mir das
auch ein bisschen abverdienen dieses
schöne glück nicht
der nächste und letzte ausschnitt aus
dem film den ich gerne zeigen möchte hat
zu tun glaube ich mit einem der
höhepunkte in ihrem glücklichen leben
und das ist ja auch der grund der reise
zurück zum zirkus knie wo sie 1970 eine
ganz große nummer die sie berühmt
gemacht der mit den elefanten jetzt
haben sich das wieder erleben und
problemlos kamen sie wieder auf den
elefanten jetzt ja es war eine art
besuch zu zu mein lieblingstier die
elefanten der elefant mit dem ich die
nummer gemacht habe 1970 der ist ja
leider gestalten aber einfach der
elefant an sich ist für mich etwas vom
unglaublichen nicht dass diese 34 tonnen
hier mit so einer unglaublichen kraft
dass er die könnten ja in zehn sekunden
einen menschen zu erdrücken und
zermalmen und töten aber die sind so
sensibel so empfindlich so intelligent
und das rührt mich dieses gerührt
mächtig
[Musik]
die ganze idee ist dass das wir hier die
alte nummer noch mal gucken wollten und
vielleicht auch wieder aufnehmen
dort im film sieht man die nummer von
1970 und wiesn mit den richtig ich nehme
mein den elefanten und wir gucken
zusammen
diese nummer an nicht dass das ist schon
eine lustige situation nicht unglaublich
schönes bild das würde jeden verliehene
film noch aufwerten wie er da sitzt ist
der blick zurück auch nur schön oder
macht es ja ein bisschen melancholisch
ich weiß ist das war ja eine report
damals und ganz so heraklit weil das
eine philosophie sein ding ist der
griechische wieder so hat doch mal
gesagt in die gleichen flüsse steigen
wir umsteigen
nicht weil alles ist doch anders das
viele wasser ist geflossen ist nicht ein
bisschen melancholisch auch wieder daran
zu denken wäre man gern wieder 40 oder
so also melancholisch ist es sowieso
immer ein so ein tier macht mich immer
auch ein bisschen melancholisch nicht
wenn man denkt das ist eines der
ältesten tiere nichts das ist ja sehr
verwandt mit dem mammut und man sagt ja
das mammut ist eines der allerersten
ältesten tiere der welt überhaupt von
millionen von jahren her also das macht
ein bisschen wehmut die gegend wieso der
welt schmerz oder so aber gleichzeitig
wenn ich jetzt so die die zeit sehe das
als ich im 70 das erste mal bei knie war
bin ich auch ein bisschen stolz muss ich
sagen weil ich war der erste der vom
theater kam und im zirkus aufgetreten
ist und und und der knie der die knie
senior der hat mich geglaubt und alle
seine kollegen und andere
zirkusdirektoren und freunde haben
gesagt du das quad niemals diese frauen
ist viel zu feiern das ist ja ein meter
kommt
im theater der wird nie ankommen im
zirkus und dem knie hat an mich geglaubt
und es war ein riesenerfolg viel arbeit
aber auch dahinter mit seinem elefanten
kann man ja nicht in zwei wochen
irgendwie diese tolle nummer bauen
ja ich habe eigentlich ein jahr vorher
angefangen zu proben mit dem elefanten
nicht weil ich ich musste mich an den
elefanten gewöhnen
der elefanten hatte die mit den menschen
schon sehr viel erfahrung aber ich noch
nicht mit dem elefanten und wie ist so
ein elefant ist das ein trampel oder
sind die recht feinfühlig nein die sind
ja unglaublich feinfühlig und
hochgebildet wirklich fast sagen aber
sehr sehr intelligent die können ja
unglaublich viele kommandos ausführen
nicht stimmt es dass ein elefant nichts
vergisst wie man so sagt ja das ist
schon legendär stimmt das und das ist ja
auch so sie können dann auch nicht böse
sein mit der einem wärter oder mit einem
menschen der den elefanten plagt nicht
und das ist auch richtig so klar und ich
war beeindruckt wie sie da auf den
elefanten raufkommen und runter mit 80
ich sage es nochmal weil das sowieso
kein mensch glaubt aber im moment werde
ihrem ganzen tal gefeiert die 80
geburtstag
wie haben sie das gemacht nur schon die
beweglichkeit das ist auch viel arbeit
noch jeden tag an dem ort wo wir hier
sitzen also ich trainiere jeden tag ich
mache jeden tag zum beispiel handstände
ich stehe wirklich auf den händen und
ich brauche das nicht mehr in meine
vorstellung aber das hält mich fit nicht
so mache ich viele übungen hier auf
diesem teppich da und da übe ich alle
meine instrumente und auch gewisse
geschicklichkeitsspiele so erklären und
so das üblich alles hier und um
natürlich dieses training plus die 150
vorstellungen die ich ungefähr im jahr
mache dass er hält mich fit aber ein
ganz wichtiger faktor ist einfach das
glück dass ich gesund sein darf und
einmal hat sie nur sekundenweise dieses
glück verlassen
das sind sie während vor ein paar jahren
während der vorstellung gestürzt vom
seil gestimmt ja dass das war schon ein
das war ein dramatischer moment nicht
also wenn man so von zweieinhalb metern
richtig direkt auf den rücken fällt und
man dann spürt halt da ist etwas nicht
in ordnung nicht und es tut auch weh was
liegt da sowieso ein 1 1 wissen sie
nicht eine schildkröte die man auf den
rücken legt und sich dann nicht mehr
aufrichten kann
und dann haben die leute gelacht und
sogar geklatscht und sie haben gedacht
das kürzel er gehört zum nummer und dann
habe ich eine weile lang so da probiert
zu gewinnen und dann war mein
schwiegersohn im publikum der heißt kai
und ich wusste der rest an der war die
einzige die einzige bezugsperson
ich habe gerufen keine ja ja ich kann ja
ja ja ich und er kam an den bühnenrand
und hat gefragt was ist los und dann
haben wir gerufen
doktor ein doktor bitte ja und dann
kamen drei doktoren aus dem publikum auf
die bühne
spezialisten haben will auf die annalen
dann hat mich schon ein bisschen der
schalk gepackt ich habe dann gesagt habe
sind sie wirklich doktor der lange ja
ich bin allgemeiner arzt sondern sie
sind sie auch doktor ja ich bin herz
herzchirurg und dann war noch eine frau
daran der uns sind sie auch ärztin
das sagt sie ja ich bin neurologin hat
sich noch nie so viel genommen
dann hatten die den denn die ambulanz
gerufen und so kam ich dann ins spital
und wieder gearbeitet und jetzt stehen
sie wieder auf der bühne können sich
bewegen wieder der glückspilz dimitri
haben sie trotzdem auch irgendwo angst
vor dem moment wo dann der allerletzte
vorhang fällt
ja also da muss ich sagen ja und nein
also ich habe nicht eigentlich angst vor
dem tod weil ich weiß dass ich meine
seele weiterlebt dass ich einfach da bin
dass ich auch nahe stehenden menschen
wieder begegne in der anderen welt in
der geistigen welt und so weiter ich
glaube auch an eine reinkarnation aber
das tut mir leider nicht die angst
nehmen und vor dem sterben im sinn von
leiden müssen kranksein lang und
abhängig werden von der pflege und das
ist natürlich ich glaube alle menschen
haben das nicht klar und was wenn man so
sagen darf ist der ideale tod für den
clown in der manege
ja das habe ich immer gedacht jahre lang
habe ich immer gesagt mein traum wäre
auf die bühne oder in der manege sterben
aber gerade dort dass ich das erlebnis
hatte mit den beiden gebrochenen wirbeln
da hab ich gedacht nein also so auf die
bühne sterben ist einfach doch für das
publikum nicht sehr angenehm ja also ich
verzichte jetzt auf diese version klang
der wieder ans publikum denkt dass er
glücklich machen will durch sein ganzes
leben
ich habe mal erich maria remarque
gelesen vergessen können ist das
geheimnis ewiger jugend wir werden alt
durch erinnerung und sitze den clown
dimitri gegenüber und denke das stimmt
überhaupt nicht sie sind jung wirken wie
früher aber ihre erinnerung geben sie
nicht her
also gehe ich hoffe natürlich dass sich
in guter erinnerung bleiben werde und
ich meine wir künstler vor allem wir
bühnenkünstler über so haben ja sehr
viele möglichkeiten und zu verewigen ja
auch jetzt unser gespräch sind ja da
gefilmt
das wird vielleicht in 100 jahren
das vielleicht noch gucken wenn es nicht
verfault oder wenn es nicht die würmer
fressen aber dass das ist schon auch
schön nicht aber mir ist eigentlich
wichtiger dass dass ich noch etwas
hinterlassen kann also wie unser theater
unsere schule das ebenso genannt
nachhaltig ist nicht das da sofort
nachhaltig das gefällt mir irgendwie wir
wünschen es ihnen hier wünschen es uns
wir wünschen uns fahren dass das noch
lange nicht der fall sein wird und das
wird es auch nicht bedanke mich sehr
herzlich dass sie und sie in ihrem
trainings atelier empfangen haben
[Musik]